[Music]  melissa etheridge makes a motherhood  confession it she's gotten high with her  kids I have smoked with my older two it  was funny at first and and then then  they realized it's it's a very natural  you know end of the day and it brings it  brings you closer so I'd much rather  have a smoke with my grown kids than a  than a drink oh god no those kids are  both adults daughter Bailey is now 20  while son Beckett is 18 melissa is  speaking out about cannabis as part of  Yahoo's new series weed and the American  family the singer first started smoking  regularly while undergoing chemo  treatments for breast cancer in 2004  life is is not easy Melissa also calls  pot the best marital aid saying it helps  her let go over inhibitions on date  night with wife Linda I've already made  the reservations and everything I'm so  proud of myself  [Music]